une plante médicinale est une plante
utilisée pour ses vertus thérapeutiques
elle possède donc des propriétés
bénéfiques pour la santé humaine
à la réunion les géraniums rosa est
connu pour ses nombreuses applications
son huile essentielle est utilisée par
les plus grands parfumeurs du monde
mais ce pélargonium qui révèle au
toucher un parfum délicat de rose est
riche d'autres vertus elle adore la
petite france dans les années 60
d'uranium n'a fini presque dans les eaux
mais pas tout à fait génie parfois me
contre pertes ali rbati ans en place un
petit peu sur le terrain et plaindre
ailleurs douteuses uranium pourquoi un
géranium parce que plein de vertus sujet
rogers depuis 97 relance à mafate
d'uranium et m'a appris que en faisant
du géranium beau pub on peut d affaires
sur l'utilisation de l'huile essentielle
que ce qui se faisait pas avant
ses vertus m'a dit peut-être deux trois
petits points ou c'est que c'est
intéressant tout le monde connais tu
vois les essayent soulage azote
rapidement pour malo d'en prendre un
petit peu de géraniums ici sur la joue
cet adam et les carriers un petit point
j'ai un coup de pied sur la dent on va
voir ses impeccables
c'est vraiment rapide et très très très
efficace en peu de temps
mais la feuille aussi de manifestants
avec voilà une feuille de petites
feuilles comme ça pour un litre d'eau
trop hâtif oeil pour un bon litre de
haut
en infusion bonne une bonne petite
tisane pour la grippe
sinon l'huile de géranium une fois
distillée à distillation fait lui le
géranium les
une connu ici pour les marmailles que
dans le vert les marmailles que nana
problèmes de
vers des parents est donné dans le temps
un goutte d'huile essentielle de
géranium sur un sucre ou bien d'un petit
cuillère de miel pour les verts et
c'était la tisane connu dans le temps
lontan
mais aujourd'hui moi personnellement mal
à apprendre utiliser autrement et on a
remarqué mois là mais apprécie ses
vertus parce que les limbes ont perverti
vraiment lui l'essentiel géraniums
laissant iranium pour les problèmes de
peau impeccable pour les problèmes de
rip utilisa lui aussi dans une petit
teaser avec du miel tout jouer avec du
miel en interne jamais prendre lui tout
seul toujours guy miel l'huile
essentielle de géranium et efficace sur
les coupures les blessures les brûlures
donc un bon peu d'affaires pour prendre
avec ça et c'est pour ça que c'est pour
moi un peu un plantes magiques avec ses
huiles que les difficiles d'euros 10
pour un produire mais qui peut produire
un peu idiote que les très très très
apprécié et de moon aussi apprécié à
lille
une infusion de la panne a aidé à nice
nous a bien mangé là et nous va boire ça
juste après pour bien digérer voilà le
petit isard n'est pas née alice à nice
bien mélanger la peut rajouter un petit
peu de marjolaine dedans il fera pas de
mal voilà les à 5,6 personne n'avait à
la dose ou cinq six personnes on va
mettre ça dans un petit récipient là
pour verser là dessus de l'eau que la
bouillie de sawtche hauts-de-seine
on va laisser ça voilà la plante
l'eau commence à changer de couleur la
voix bien et ça commence à être parfumée
aussi on sent la bonne tisane les tiges
les plus costauds les plus durs et ça va
repartir les bosons temps nasa veut
repartir d'ici un mois et demi deux mois
aura une petite coupe encore à faire
ouais géraniums c'est peut-être assez
fort assez résistante mais en petit koné
compères parce qu'il ya trop de pluie
c'est l'appui la nuit qui fatigue du
géranium donc au moins une essentielle
uranium la réunion en autriche en or ici
que nous arriverons à valoriser ce
serait vraiment un bon bien pour les
hauts de l'île relancé le géranium et
repartir dans d'autres conditions